remember my rant about recount versus
audit and the reasons that a recount if
the allegations of irregularities are
true would not really uncover very much
about those irregularities and really a
full audit is what would be necessary I
won't rehash that rant now but that rant
is particularly relevant given what's
going on in parts of Michigan right now
because tons of ballots are being
designated as unreachable listen to this
a third of the precincts in Wayne County
which is where detroit michigan is could
be disqualified because of problems with
those ballots Michigan's largest county
not surprisingly voted overwhelmingly
for the Democratic candidate Hillary
Clinton in the november eighth
presidential elections but officials are
unable to reconcile vote totals for 610
of the sixteen hundred and eighty
precincts during a countywide canvas of
vote results late in November most of
those again in heavily Democratic
Detroit and you had a number of
circumstances where ballots in precinct
poll books didn't match those of voting
machine print out reports this happened
in nearly sixty percent of the precincts
and here's why this is such a big deal
according to state law when you have a
precinct where the poll books don't
match with the ballots it cannot be
recounted and if that happens they say
you know what we're just gonna stick
with the orig original election results
this is fundamentally a system Pat which
is set up to prevent the fixing of
problems on Election Day if there are
discrepancies and we'll just go with
what we had on Election Day the reason
that we're looking at this is because
there appear to be problems with the
results from election day it's a system
that is designed not to be able to solve
the problems it's there for yeah there
always seems to be these issues in urban
areas where it's more democratically
leaning yeah we've seen in 2004 in ohio
and florida in two thousand it just
continues so it's just a coincidence
yeah don't worry about it there's
nothing strategic or or or planned about
that it's just just merely a coincidence
but the elections director
for the city of the Troy is Daniel
Baxter he blamed the discrepancies on 87
optical scanners which reportedly broke
on Election Day a lot of them jamming
when voters put their ballots in this
can result in erroneous vote counts this
can result in our all sorts of mistakes
and irregularities and in the meantime
this is where it gets even crazier the
Michigan Court of Appeals ruled that the
recount asked for by green party
candidate Jill Stein won't be done
because she has no standing to ask for a
recount here's the way that that that
the court decided if you are a candidate
who does not stand a chance of winning
if the recount goes in a different way
then you are not considered to have
standing to ask for the recount and
because of the small vote margin between
Trump and Clinton in Michigan if indeed
a recount change the results it wouldn't
lead to Jill Stein winning if anything
it would lead to Hillary Clinton winning
instead of Donald Trump and as a result
Pat a court has said since Jill Stein
was not cheated out of this election she
didn't win no matter what the exact
totals were she doesn't have the right
to demand a recount in the margin
between Trump and Clinton was only
eleven thousand votes that was a fifth
of a percentage point mm the recount
should just be automatic in that case
Jill Stein is absolutely correct here
that we need to have a recount and I I'm
getting emails from people saying David
why not just count the paper ballots and
there's sort of two reasons number one
as I mentioned when you have a
discrepancy between the the paper
ballots and the electronic record then
you just stick with the election results
which is insane i mean it's a it's a
ridiculous system at its core but also
there's no guarantee that the paper
ballots actually represent all of the
votes that were cast on election day if
you have the number of ballots not
matching the certified results there's
no guarantee that by recounting the
ballots you're actually going to have
the correct number of ballots as usual
yet another issue that
disproportionately is affecting clinton
voters and as Pat pointed out when this
happened in Florida when this happened
in Ohio in two thousand and two thousand
four just a coincidence but it
disproportionately impacted places where
voters ten
to be tend to be more democratic than
Republican need an audit the recount
will not do anything even if it happens
and it appears that even that is not
going to happen